hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen ja heute meine damen und
herren und geschlechtsneutral einer weht
hier außen vor gelassen dafür stehe ich
mit meiner herzlich willkommen hier
heute zu einem neuen video auf meinem
kanal und der ein oder andere hardcore
luca fan hat sich überhaupt fans haben
sollte
er wird schon wissen dass ich ein video
über diese app bereits vor einem jahr
hochgeladen habe und zwar bei die pace
er ja wie gesagt habe dazu schon ein
video hochgeladen
ja die app
ändert ein bild allerdings ist vor
einigen wochen ein update zu dieser app
rausgekommen und ihr seht es hier schon
eingeblendet ich habe ein ziel von mir
gemacht und kann nun sagen dass der
eindruck verändert wird dass ich lächle
dass ich einen bart habe ich mein noch
mehr bad geht eigentlich nicht ich kann
mich auch eltern machen ich kann mir
eine neue frisur machen ich kann meine
haarfarbe ändern und mir eine brille
photoshop um euch das einfach mal anhand
einer brille zu zeigen
die app lädt das nun und so leger das
update hat die app echt krass verbessert
also früher sei es echt brutal scheiße
aus als ich in der app aufgesetzt
bekommen aber vielleicht lag das auch an
mir auf jeden fall will ich jetzt sagen
dass wir direkt mal hier in den teppe
bad reingehen und ich würde mal so ein
hipster bad geben als
wenn ein bisschen klima wer wird es gar
nicht mal so scheiße aussehen jeder
bisschen aus wie david beckham
wir haben ja noch andere bad arten wie
beispielsweise ein schnurrbart
ich kann doch einfach mal auf rasiert
klicken ich weiß nicht ob ich dann
zumindest
habe nicht mehr stoppeln haben ja sieht
geil aus wir können jetzt auch mal auf
alter klicken und können mich mal alt
aussehen lassen
das ganz
ich seh 1 1 aus wie mein opa jetzt
können wir einfach nicht auch frisuren
klicken einige leute wollen ja dass ich
endlich mal zum friseur gehe ich hatte
echt überlegt wie eine glatze mal machen
zu lassen weil ich möchte ich will ich
finds halt mal
juli ich werde mir doch keine glatze
machen sie eigentlich schon echt lustig
aus obwohl mein kopf so ein bisschen wie
der erdnuss aussieht schnitt einfach
killer genannt
das einfach glatze zu nennen dann kann
ich mir hier auf einen pony wachsen
lassen
ich sehe aus wie ein wischmopp wir
können ja auch mal anklicken
ich lasse meine scharia grad ein
bisschen länger wachsen aber ich glaube
das lasse ich jetzt auch aber das ist
echt nice vor allem wie das da ansetzt
an den seiten dass die app hat sich
krass verbessert ich habe jetzt mal
auffällig geklickt
ist kein großer unterschied ist nur an
den seiten so ein bisschen weniger und
dann können wir auch nochmal auf gerader
klicken
das sieht das ganze wahrscheinlich so
aus wie als ich ja es hat sich gar
nichts verändert allerdings ist dieses
wunderschönes hält viel von mir
natürlich nicht das einzige foto was ich
heute vorbereitet habe sondern ich habe
auch noch ein bild von dem ihn von bts
rausgesucht ich hoffe ich habe ihn
richtig ausgesprochen alle bts werden
gehört bitte in die kommentare schreiben
er hat ein sehr junges gesicht deswegen
bin ich gerade hier gespannt was
passiert wenn ich ihnen noch jünger
aussehen lasse york passiert gar nichts
ich habe jetzt mal auf als geklickt da
bin ich sehr gespannt
alter selbst das sieht nicht brutal alt
aus asiaten genießen einfach dieses
privileg dass sie nie irgendwie
alterserscheinungen hasen dass ich meine
das ist mega krasse können hier vorne
jetzt auch auf eindruck klicken
das ist dann so ein bisschen so filter
mäßig also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
auf make-up klicke ich weiß ich habe
hier sogar make-up vielleicht tragen hat
also gerade an den augen glaube ich
sieht man das ja doch nicht was ich hier
sogar viel interessanter fans wäre das
lächeln und zwar der seinen mund
geschlossen
deswegen klicke ich jetzt einfach mal
auf lächeln auf den ersten lächeln
filter von dir werde ich heute nacht auf
jeden fall auch träumen lustig wer ist
denke ich auch wenn wir ihm einfach mal
so 17 bad geben würden ja so lustig ist
jetzt auch nicht und was ich bei immer
noch interessant wer wäre die farbe der
haare einfach mal zu rot
die sache ist sieht halt nicht mal kaka
aus sollen wir nun allerdings direkt zur
nächsten person die ich heute
vorbereitet habe und zwar ist es katja
krasa wird da kann man mal klatschen sie
hat auch ihren mund geschlossen das
heißt ich klicke hier jetzt auch mal auf
lächeln da bin ich wirklich sehr
gespannt wie das ding ist es könnten
halt wirklich ihre zähne seien mal
schauen was passiert wenn ich jetzt hier
auf verärgert darauf klickt sieht er so
ein bisschen enttäuscht aus haarfarbe
von der katja mach ich mal schwarz man
kennt sie ja nur mit diesem
wasserstoffblonden
es sieht nicht schlecht aus
das muss man sagen katja macht dir deine
haare mal schwarz alter ich glaube dass
mehr komplett neuer look hat ja mit
einer brille würde so aussehen wie es
die app jetzt gleich uns anzeigen wird
uns ja da hat die app ein bisschen
verpackt und eine katja in einigen
jahren wird es so aussehen
haase sieht halt bisschen wie wollte man
aus allerdings sieht sie dort auch nicht
schlecht drauf aus die sache ist nur
dass sie hat bei dem foto auch kraß
geschminkt war ihm das kann natürlich
nie wow ich mach mal weiter mit einem
anderen foto und zwar ist es montana
black da bin ich auch sehr sehr sehr
sehr gespannt so wie bei eigentlich
ebenbild was ich bisher genommen habe er
guckt hier auch ziemlich normal neutral
würde ich sagen das heißt wir zaubern
doch erst mal ein schönes lächeln ins
gesicht dass sie die aber absolut
scheiße aus ich habe jetzt mal auf
lächeln zwei geklickte 7
alter es sieht immer noch scheiße aus
aber es könnte echt sein und wenn man
auch verärgert klickt ja
das sieht so aus nach erst was hier
wirklich komplett montana black mit
einem vollbart
er sieht
übelst abgrenzt aus was ist wenn wir ihm
jetzt mal hier so einen schnurrbart
er sieht halt wirklich direkt aus als
wäre er 50 jahre alt ist der 31 oder
sohn also monte ich bin ganz ehrlich da
würde ich tatsächlich wieder zurück ins
original gehen weil ohne bart ja dass
das passt besser wir können auch noch
mal auf eindruck klicken und ihm ein
bisschen make-up verpasst
ich glaube das machen wir direkt mal
wieder weg und bei der haarfarbe wenn
ich jetzt hier auf rothaarig dicke da
wird nichts passieren weil ja gut seine
cap hat sich verändert als nächstes foto
habe ich eine sehr gute freundin von mir
ausgesucht und zwar sandra bald wie
sandra nicht kennt die ist ein bisschen
komisch ja falls ihr solche videos öfter
sehen wollt dann folgt mir gern bei
instagram instagram das hier ist auf
jeden fall das bild was ich von der
sandra ausgesucht habe er zunächst
einmal möchte ich wissen was passiert
wenn ich auf welle clique weil
da passiert gar nichts ich glaube ihre
haut ihre haut hat sich ein bisschen
verändert interessant fände ich auch ein
lächeln weil man sie zwar ihren mund und
ihre zunge aber man sieht jetzt nicht
irgendwie irre 10
mein gott du siehst aus wie der teufel
nichts gegen dich sandra nicht absolut
beschissen aus ich gehe ich auf lächelns
ey
also es es könnte echt sein ihre augen
das sieht schon echt creepy aus wenn ich
auch verärgert clique sieht die ganze
person
ja irgendwie wollte nur ihren mund weit
heruntergezogen die haarfarbe von der
sandra mache ich jetzt mal schwarz ich
glaube das hatte sie
a
sondern auch auf den kopf
das ist natürlich alles nur ein job
machen sie jetzt auch mal ein bisschen
älter
sandra falls
o
lösche das
das ist das beste der besten filter
bisher ich glaub so wie es andere safe
aussehen wenn sie später als und sandra
mit einem schnurrbart sieht so aus wir
uns die app dass sie jetzt zeigt die
sache ist es passt halt sogar irgendwie
als vorletzte person habe ich mir jule
rausgesucht meine freundin das ist
irgendwie so ein bild was sie mal für
einen perso gemacht hat oder so also
habe ich klicke auch jemand auf lech
domain got you know what the [ __ ] also
ich meine das sieht echt aus aber es
sieht echt komisch aus und lächelnd 2
jak
juli als verärgerte personen mein gott
das ist ein für 1 juli oder der
haarfarbe mache ich sie jetzt mal
schwarzer bin ich oltra gespannt wie
meine freude mit schwarzen haaren aus
also ich find's schön
aber
blond
ist auch schön
machen sie jetzt noch mal hier komplett
blond ja okay das ist eher orange und
rothaarig würde mich auch mal
interessieren bei der lieben julie julia
steamy der haare rot färben dur mit
brille wäre ich auch gespannt weil sie
muss normalerweise eine brille tragen
und ja genauso wie juli tatsächlich mit
brille aus als letztes bild habe ich
wieder ein foto von mir selbst genommen
allerdings kein normales foto wo ich
irgendwie straight in die kamera guckt
und keine miene verzehre was man gut
bearbeiten kann sondern ein bild was
juli von mir gemacht hat indem sie meine
nase hochgezogen hat und denkt an ein
ernst
sie konnten in diesem foto kein gesicht
finden versuchen sie jetzt mit einem
anderen foto darf nicht geklappt hat mit
dem bild was juli vor mir gemacht hat wo
sie meine nase
ich sehe aus wie ein schwein da das
ganze leider nicht geklappt hat da die
face es darin keine gesicht erkannt hat
er würde ich das wieder an der stelle
jetzt auch beenden falls es euch
gefallen hat und ich denke halo kwadrat
sei jetzt zu gut für aktien
ich weiß ich hab dazu vor einem jahr
bereits ein video gemacht und jetzt
mache ich mein zweites video dazu habe
ich finde gerade mit seiner app kann man
sehr viel content liefern
und vielleicht könnte ich ja auch mal
eure bilder dort mit der app bearbeiten
wollte da bock drauf habt dann gibt's
hier unten dem video einen daumen hoch
das zeigt auf jeden fall dass euch das
ganze gefällt und in der folge gerne
einen zweiten bzw dritten part haben
möchte und schreibt mir und in die
kommentare
welche ja ich einen effekt
beziehungsweise filter ihr bei welcher
person am krassesten fahndet
[Musik]
zum 1